a brilliant player can get a strong hand
cracked go on tilt and lose his mind
along with every single chip in front of
them this is why the World Series of
Poker is decided over a No Limit Hold'em
table
some people pros even won't play No
Limit they can't handle the swings
that's Matt Damon in the 1998 movie
rounders about the big risks big money
world of professional poker where
players can spend a lifetime getting to
the top then there's the story of Maria
konnikova in just a year and a half she
went from not knowing the difference
between a parent of flush to being a
poker champion with an endorsement deal
on the Pro Tour konnikova put a
successful writing career on hold to
immerse herself in the game how and why
she did it is the subject of her
fascinating new book released just this
week the biggest bluff with this bet at
the 2018 PokerStars Caribbean adventure
Maria konnikova called her opponent's
bluff winning nearly 85 thousand dollars
and staking the place in the high-stakes
world of professional poker so this is
your first taste of a big victory in a
poker tournament it was a stunning
victory for someone who had only been
playing the game for one year had you
played poker no I'd never played a
single hand of Poker I didn't know the
rules I didn't know the
thing for the first thing I have a
slightly non-traditional background she
did know about psychology konnikova put
a PhD to use writing books and
contributing articles to The New Yorker
but when she and her family suffered a
series of devastating hardships
konnikova became unnerved and turned of
all places to cards how do you find the
way to write about
I mean poker doesn't jump to mind when I
think of it oh no and it didn't jump to
my mind I just started reading
voraciously everything I could find
about chance about luck she came across
one of the 20th century's top thinkers
in science and math john von neumann and
his foundational text on game theory not
only was von Neumann and poker player
but poker was the basis of game theory
according to konnikova von Neumann
believed No Limit Texas Hold'em
represented the perfect combination of
the known and unknown making poker the
ideal proxy for life I have my cards
that I know you have yours that you know
there are cards that we have in common
that we can both see but then we have to
make the best decisions we can
with incomplete information with what we
know and I thought this might be a way
in
why don't I learn to play the game and
actually use that as a story arc to
explore chance konnikova may have defied
the odds but she had an ace in the hole
side Al's got control of the action
though he's the preflop raiser Eric
Seidel she convinced the eight-time
World Series of Poker champion with more
than 30 million dollars in lifetime
earnings to coach her for a year while
she worked on the book I didn't know
Eric Schneider like from Bob
for the bait then I realized that he was
the guy in rounders he was the guy in
the red visor somehow miraculously to do
this I love the concept I went back and
read a few a New Yorker articles and I
and I thought this is really gonna be a
fun show so how do you go about figuring
out how to then teach side all started
with homework assigning books on the
game for his apprentice to read which
led to a running dialogue about how to
think through a hand because I was such
a newbie and had never played before I
just want him to tell me how do I play
these two cards what do I do here
tell me do I fold do I raise why do me
the answer me the answer and he never
did no matter how much I begged him he
would say well let's think it through in
the book konnikova chronicles her
journey from daily online tournaments on
her laptop all the way to the seaside
city of Monte Carlo I mean it's you know
James Bond Ville it's kind of this tiny
tiny postage stamp of a country
it's on a cliff over the Mediterranean
beautiful pristine beaches everyone is
rich and everyone actually is rich you
have to be quite wealthy to live in
Montecarlo and it runs on casinos it's
where konnikova
debunked a common misperception we all
talk about a poker face there's so much
more to trying to read someone than just
looking at their face at a poker table
absolutely and in fact what I learned is
that looking at a face is
counterproductive what the research
shows is that a lot more tells if you're
looking for something physical or in the
hands poker hands look ahead that we
should be much more concerned about the
information our hands are giving off it
wasn't all glitz and glamor konnikova
writes about the highs and the lows like
failing in her first appearance at the
World Series of Poker in Las Vegas which
she says is like setting $10,000 on fire
along with the challenges of breaking
into a world that's 97 percent male I've
been called everything under the Sun at
the poker table I've been propositioned
at a poker table actually proposition 2
can go days and days and days without
seeing another woman and it breaks my
heart that there's
an image some deserved some not of why
women don't play the game hand by hand
konnikova discovered that unlike other
forms of gambling poker is a game of
skill not chance as she puts it you can
win with the worst hand or lose with the
best it's something she learned
firsthand in the Caribbean before taking
home that first trophy she was nearly
knocked out of the tournament after
losing with pocket aces the best hand
you can be dealt Eric was watching and
he saw the hand and he said yeah you
messed up but he um along had been
teaching you you got it but he said put
it behind you which is such a great
lesson in life we're all gonna mess up
exactly he said move on forget it put it
out of your mind we're his exact words
put it out of your mind and just take it
one hand at a time it's one of many
lessons konnikova has learned from poker
why she fell in love with the game and
continues to play professionally you
have to be okay with the fact that you
don't control it all you can do
everything in your power and yet
variance chance the noise of the
universe it's just it's never gonna go
away I think we need to kind of Bluff
ourselves that we have more control than
we actually do you can't control the
cards you can't control the other
players but you can control your own
strategy you can control your own mind
how you think about things how you react
to things what you take from experiences
this is all on you and that's what your
your focus should be poker hands Jeff a
hooker hands remember that also it's
really a read whether you like poker or
not I'm not a big poker player but you
will still be able to glean so much from
this and it actually got me a little
interested in going out and not that I'm
that great at but happy to teach you
data so hold on a second you got to do a
story on poker a book and Monte Carlo
the pictures looked really nice Dana
she's fascinating great story